Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong
friends talk about life
for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are going to be pulling
back another curtain.
And behind that curtain is two men
who have been going to therapy
for a certain length of time.
And we're just gonna do a little check-in.
I thought you were gonna say
you're gonna pull back that curtain,
and it's two men and it's our therapists.
They're not joining us today.
They're not joining us.
We can say anything we
want about our therapist.
But we won't. Well, we will.
We're gonna be talking about
our experience thus far
in therapy and how we're viewing that,
what kind of stuff is happening.
And let me, just in case
you're immediately like,
I don't care.
I'm not from Los Angeles.
You guys obviously are.
Listen, therapy's not just
for boys in Los Angeles.
Therapy can be for anybody.
We, and it's been beneficial to us.
We don't know if any, we
don't know if you think that,
but we used to think that.
Yeah, we're speaking to our former selves.
And we've, therapy's come
up a lot in conversations
because we're talking
about processing our lives,
and therapy is a big part of
that, an important part of it.
But we thought-
You have a hair that-
Oh, I can see it.
There we go.
I know you don't like when hairs-
How's that?
Are in that place or that place.
And if people don't point
it out, you get upset.
So I'm just letting you know right now.
I don't want you to be
looking back at this
and be like, why did you let
me do that the whole time?
I'd hate for my therapist to
be the one to bring it up.
But what we haven't done is
devote an extended conversation
to the topic in some time, if ever.
So now's that time.
I will say, I have a little update,
recent travel excursion to.
I mean, thankfully,
certain places in the
country have kind of,
we're not out of the pandemic,
but certain, there's certain places,
and if you take certain precautions,
you can feel somewhat safe to travel.
I've kinda taken advantage of that.
But also this was a wedding of a friend
that took place in Kansas City
that I was gonna go to regardless.
But thankfully I could sort
of feel safe in doing so.
But the most notable thing,
besides a beautiful wedding,
beautiful couple getting married
and beginning a beautiful life together,
which is not what I'm gonna talk about,
is the fact that we
stayed at a haunted hotel.
Okay.
Now, you know me.
I'm into horror stuff.
I like the idea of haunting.
I'm pretty skeptical about the paranormal.
I can act like I'm really into it,
but in my heart of hearts, in
my heart of hearts, I'm just,
this is probably all made up, right?
But that did not stop me
from being very enthusiastic
about the ghost tour.
And this is coming from
someone who's been on
a few ghost tours.
It's hard for me to get enthusiastic.
The two that I went on with you,
and one in New Orleans,
and where was the other one?
London.
It was a Jack the Ripper tour.
That's right.
Oh, boy, I just,
I kinda needed to just
turn in for the night
about halfway through.
Well, let me tell you
why I was particularly
excited about this one.
Both of those ghost tours
were going around a city,
and then like coming up to a corner,
and looking at a building,
and hearing somebody who had
just been told information,
what to say about this thing.
Are you telling me you had an
actual ghost give the tour?
Well, it wasn't that good,
but it's somewhere between the
original experience and that.
Which is?
A ghost tour of a hotel
where you are staying.
First of all-
Okay.
We're in a different category.
And secondly, well, there's
actually three points to this.
The second point is-
Uh-oh, the points are expanding.
The guy doing the tour,
and this isn't something
I knew ahead of time,
but the guy doing the tour
wasn't just talking about things
that other people had said.
He was telling his own stories
in being an employee for
15 years at the hotel.
So many of his stories were
like, this happened to me.
Again, never experienced that.
And then the third thing was,
the bride and groom had experienced
some metaphysical unexplained
phenomena, you might say.
Okay, what?
The first night in the hotel.
Well, when you're
contemplating a marriage.
The night before.
Well, the night before the ghost tour.
Things could go really wild when-
The night before the ghost tour.
So...
Oh, and also Locke told
me that something happened
in his room.
I'll tell you about that in a second.
Apparently they wake up,
and the bedside table little
deal where the drawer,
it's a drawer.
What would you call a bedside little thing
that's got a drawer and it's a table?
Bedside table.
My bedside table's got two drawers, man.
My previous one had three drawers.
I don't think that's technically a table.
Like in furniture speak,
I don't think it's a table
if it's got a drawer.
Bedside chest of drawers?
It's definitely not that.
There's probably like
a French word for it.
I'd like to get to the haunted part.
The drawer had opened in the night, okay?
Okay, well, that could happen.
They closed the drawer,
and the drawer opens again
before their very eyes.
Now, this could be like
the gravity of the,
it could be like the floor.
It's an old hotel.
Like the gravity can open the drawers.
Yeah.
But then the, a water bottle,
like a, whatever, the one that you have.
The one everybody's got.
Like a Nalgene?
No, the like Hydro Flask.
Hydro Flask, okay.
So like a metal water bottle
was on that same table,
and it, at some point in this process,
began to do that thing where
you know like a bottle
isn't quite settling,
and it's kinda like, kinda
rotating a little bit,
like right before, like a coin
settling and then stopping.
Okay, yeah.
That was happening,
but it was just happening indefinitely.
It was just like, okay, this
bottle is gonna do this.
They're just watching it.
And then they stopped
it, and put it back down,
and it started doing it again.
And then they were just like, okay,
you can have your drawer open.
I don't know exactly
the sequence of events,
but 'cause I kinda heard
it as they were telling
a group of people.
And I was, it was enough
for me to be freaked out.
I have an explanation for that.
There's vibration in the hotel from like-
Hey, listen.
The laundry room.
There's always an explanation.
Or the elevator shaft.
I told you I'm a skeptic, man.
Vibration takes care of
everything I've heard so far.
But of course,
and every single thing I'm gonna tell you,
I'm not gonna tell you
everything that happens
on the ghost tour,
but everything, every
single thing I was told,
because like Locke and
Shepherd, after the ghost store,
because Locke had heard
somebody whispering in the vent
at like three a.m. in
Locke and Shepherd's room.
And then he actually told the
guy on the ghost tour that,
the guy giving the tour.
And he was like, oh, that's
just because all our,
the whole system is connected.
So you just heard somebody
whispering in another room.
He wasn't like feeding into it.
That's good.
Maintaining credibility.
He's kinda like the Pope.
He's like, I'm the only one
who can tell ghost stories.
Well, no, 'cause he was,
he had many people on the tour
were saying things that
had happened to them,
and he was validating some things.
But if it was, if he actually
thought it was the truth-
He's keeping it real.
But when Locke and Shepard
were, after the tour,
they were like, Dad, what
do you think about this?
I was like, well, you wanna
know what I really think?
I was scared at multiple
points on that ghost tour,
especially the moment when
we were standing at the
top of the stairs,
and some little girls who apparently knew
that the ghost tour comes by their room,
and they could hear the guy talking.
Jay is his name.
He's actually, he's wearing one
of those headset microphones
with a speaker that's around his neck,
like a tour guide does.
You know what I'm saying?
So that he can just
speak in a normal volume,
but everyone can hear him.
So he's like coming by your room,
you know. oh, Jay's there.
He's doing the tour.
They waited until he was
in the middle of the story,
and they started going.
And he had already just told us a story
about somebody being in a room
and seeing the handle move.
Oh.
And so then he's telling us a story,
and that's when these little
girls in the room started,
like taking their door
and like shaking it.
And me, and Locke, and Shepherd
were like standing a
little bit down the hall,
and we immediately run up
next to the tour guide.
Before you have time to process,
oh, this is probably somebody
just playing a trick,
but I still, was just legitimately scared.
Did the girls come out and say, gotcha?
They just laughed from within the room,
which actually was sort of creepy,
little girl laughter through a door.
But I said, having said all that,
I believe that if you just, if you put me,
put my back against the
wall and telling me,
I've gotta give you an honest answer,
I think there's probably a
natural explanation for all this.
There's a reason that it happens at night.
There's a reason that it
happens during the so-called
witching hour after three a.m.
That's because you're
usually, you've been asleep,
and you're waking up, and you're not,
your senses aren't complete.
You're just pouring water on yourself now.
You okay?
It was haunted, man.
My tea was haunted.
So in other words, what I'm saying is that
I think that there's probably
almost always a natural explanation,
but I'm not sure.
I'm open to the fact that places-
That's not fun.
Places can be haunted,
and it's more fun to believe
that the place is haunted.
So, and this guy, Jay, he's.
Oh, the other thing that happened.
A lot of famous people
have been to this hotel.
In fact, the room that the
bride and groom are staying in
is the room that Harry Truman slept in
the night that he found out
that he won the presidency.
He went to sleep thinking
that he had lost,
and they woke him up at
like two a.m. and said,
sir, you won.
And then there's another room that
is a room where like Al Capone
would come and play cards and stuff.
And they were like, he
would sit right here,
and he could see this through
this window and this window.
He had both entrances covered
in case the feds came in,
he could go out this way or whatever.
So it's been around 100 years.
It's got this storied history.
Where is it?
It is outside of Kansas City, Missouri.
Okay.
So he's telling a story
about some famous person
that was on the tour.
And then, I can't remember who it was.
So then we get to the next spot,
and I kinda, me, and Locke, and Shepherd
were sort of ahead of everybody,
and we kinda walk up, and
we're right next to him,
and kind of waiting for
the group to gather.
He said, and he was like,
you look like a famous guy.
You famous?
May I include you in
subsequent tour mentions?
And that was like,
I never know how to answer that question.
So I was like, to some people.
Yeah.
And he was like, Naked and Afraid.
Okay.
Was he changing the subject,
or was he thinking you were on that show?
He thought, he was like, I was a guy.
'Cause I was like, no,
I've been Naked and Afraid on YouTube.
Haven't been on that show, but-
Naked just because you-
He said that,
no, he said, there's a
guy on season so-and-so
of Naked and Afraid that
looked a lot like you.
But then the next day when I see Jay,
and now of course, we're all masked
as we're walking around this thing, so.
And of course, if you don't
watch our content regularly
and you see me now, you may
not immediately recognize me
'cause my hair is so different.
So the next day he's like, hey man,
Good Mythical Morning, of course.
I didn't put it together.
My daughter watches a lot,
and I watch it with her.
So, love what you guys do, but.
But still, not Naked and Afraid.
I thought you were from Naked and Afraid.
You should really look into that.
You got demoted overnight, man.
So shout out to Jay at
the, it's the Elms Hotel,
historic hotel.
They have a European lap
pool in the basement.
Do you know what a European lap pool is?
Isn't it like an indoor,
it's just like a ditch that-
It's a track that goes in
a circle that you swim.
Oh a track?
It's like, it's a canal.
It's a ring. It's a moat.
That's wide enough for
a person to swim in,
and it goes in a circle.
It's kinda awesome.
And when you get to the end of one side-
It's a circle, there's no end.
Well, it's an oval.
It's a very long oval like this.
Oh, wow.
At one end of the oval,
well, at one end of the oval
there's a ghost, of course.
Right.
But-
Naked and Afraid.
At the other end, there's a hot tub
and a cold plunge pool
right next to each other.
So we had fun kinda going
back and forth between those.
I've never seen a racetrack made of water.
There's a part of me that was just like,
how necessary is this?
'Cause it couldn't just be-
You didn't try it out?
Oh, I swam in it. I like, oh yeah.
What was it like turning,
banking the corners?
NASCAR?
Yeah, I mean,
I felt like I was about to
come right out of the thing.
As long as you are going
around those corners,
were your like feet and hands hitting?
It's big.
Wow.
It's very cool.
In the bottom of a hotel.
They probably just were gonna make a pool,
and then they were like, you know what?
Let's just fill in the middle
except for a little bit,
and let's call it a European swim track.
No one will know the difference.
I think it's the only
European lap pool in America.
What?
That's what they said. I think?
Okay.
I know they said in Missouri.
Hey, listen, once you start
blurring the lines of truth
with ghost tours, you can
say anything you want.
You can't believe these people.
They're not credible anymore,
and neither are you.
Man, I'll tell you right now.
If you have an opportunity to
go into a European lap pool,
and if you're in America,
that may only be available
to you in the Elms Hotel.
Apparently.
In Missouri.
Excelsior Springs, I
think is the name of it.
Okay.
You should go do it and swim some laps.
All right, let's dive into some therapy.
Ooh, is this gonna hurt?
But first, we're gonna,
we're in the midst of a
huge Black Friday sale.
Yep.
And it's over the weekend.
This comes out on Sunday,
this video version.
And so the 40% that you can get on Sunday,
and you could have
gotten the last two days,
off of everything mythical.com.
Everything.
We're extending it through
Cyber Monday, through tomorrow.
You can still get that 40% off
through the end of the day.
Okay? Think of the day
tomorrow, which is Monday.
You can also get 25% off Mythical Society
monthly memberships at mythicalsociety.com
through the end of tomorrow, Monday.
We're extending it for you.
So take advantage, take advantage,
take advantage of this stuff, guys.
The discounts are rolling in.
There's also discontinued
items that are returning
for one day only,
and that is tomorrow, Cyber Monday.
Coming out of the mythical
vault, mythical.com,
check those discontinued,
but recontinued just
for that day, tomorrow.
Get it, mythical.com
and mythicalsociety.com.
Ooh, that felt good.
It felt so good.
Felt good to do that add.
Just like therapy.
Just like the,
just knowing that people
are getting discounts.
40% is deep.
Yeah, should we even do that?
Can we call it?
Can we decide something
different right now?
Where do we begin?
I think that's the name
of Esther Perel's podcast.
Or How Was Your Day, or How's Work?
There's two of 'em.
She's a therapist.
She's great.
She's pretty great.
She's not my therapist.
This will not be as good as an episode
of Esther Perel's podcast.
No, Esther.
Esther.
Well, if you know her well, it's Esther.
No, no, no, no, it's not.
Quite the opposite, quite the opposite.
She says, quit emphasizing
the stair and emphasize the S.
You know you've crossed over.
But where do we wanna start with?
Well, let's just, let's
give some background about
how long we've been going to therapy,
maybe what got us into it.
These are the things
that have come up before,
but just for the cohesiveness of this,
of where we're headed.
And since you've been going to
therapy longer, you go first.
I think that it was 2017.
2017 was the end,
or the beginning of, didn't last long,
the longer version of
Good Mythical Morning,
if you do recall that,
where we did a bunch of
videos every single day.
And my wife had been going to therapy
for a couple of years at that point
and had been asking me,
or telling me that I should be going
based on things that she
was learning about herself
that were then immediately
sort of transferring to me.
Because I think she, like me,
thought that I didn't need therapy.
Do you know what I mean?
She thought that, okay.
I think that she thought that the one with
the things that needed to be addressed
from a professional standpoint,
it was probably her, right?
'Cause she struggled with OCD
since she was a young child.
So there was like diagnosable things,
OCD and depression, that she knew she had
and had been professionally diagnosed
by like a psychiatrist
years and years ago.
And I had never had that.
And I had always sort
of presented myself as,
well, I mean, I'm super
stable and reliable,
and I'm not saying I'm perfect,
but I don't think I need professional help
when it comes to like my
mental and emotional health.
But as she began to explore her own,
and realize, oh, it's not just about
addressing this diagnosis,
but there's a whole more to
therapy in the same way that
you might have a physical problem.
Like, oh, I hurt my knee
in this very specific way.
I need to go to the doctor.
Well, even if you haven't hurt your knee,
you're a person with a body,
and there are ongoing needs.
So having a regular physical checkup.
You see the analogy here, so.
I do.
And she started to talk to me.
She also started to be able
to see the way that I was
sort of dealing with the
immense amount of stress
that had built up in my
life over many, many years
of our, this Mythical thing
growing to where it had,
and our schedule being crazy,
and the amount of weight and
pressure on us to perform
and to keep growing the business,
and to be relevant,
and all the things that come with being
a public personality.
And she kept, she started saying,
you really should go to therapy.
And I think you should just go to my guy
because he's great,
and he's open to doing
that, having both of us.
So anyway, after, and
when, at the end of 2017,
in the midst of all that stress,
I had some physical
problems that developed
that definitely seemed
to be stress-related.
I've talked about that before.
That was when I started.
But just, I mean, to give
them the blurb though.
Well-
You went-
I had multiple, multiple things-
You had a form of blindness.
I've had multiple things
that are known to be stress induced,
like skin issues, like
psoriasis and eczema,
back issues kinda often.
So I always had those,
but the straw that broke the camel's back
was when I developed
central serous retinopathy,
which is literally when
there's like a fluid sac
that gets behind your eye
and creates a blind spot on your eye
in your field of vision.
And it was first observed,
or maybe not observed,
but first sort of recognized and labeled
when these World War I or II pilots
were coming back from war,
and a bunch of them had this condition
because they had been
under so much stress.
So there's reason to believe
that it's stress-induced,
and it is not permanent.
If it happens once, it's not
unlikely to happen again.
But anyway, I go to the
doctor, the eye doctor.
They tell me that's what this is.
It's gonna take months for
this thing to resolve itself,
which it did.
For awhile, I think, I can't
remember which eye it was,
but I basically couldn't see
in the middle of my field of
vision with one of my eyes.
And if it was like-
Was I black or wavy?
Well, it was blurry and wavy,
and made you feel like you have vertigo.
He made a connection to stress
or some inner mental working.
I made the connection to stress
when I started reading
about that condition.
Oh.
And I was like, man, okay.
Yeah, I guess,
'cause I always would say, I
don't feel stressed because,
well, I'll talk about what my process is
and what I've been working on,
but it was because I
wasn't dealing with it
in an emotional way.
I was dealing with it in a physical way.
I do believe, and I don't understand,
and I don't have the
science to back it up,
but I do believe that
there's a natural connection
to when you don't process
things emotionally
that it kinda finds way to get out of you,
and it can manifest itself physically.
So that's what led to me
having my first appointment
in sometime in like late 2017.
So it's crazy to think that
coming up on four years
of therapy.
I'm coming up on two years of therapy
in like the January, February timeframe.
So that means I started like
just a couple of months,
had a couple of in-person
sessions before the pandemic hit,
and we went to zoom meetings.
And for me it's been
pretty much every week,
except when like scheduling challenges,
or our trips or whatever.
But yeah, the reason why I got into it,
the best that I can remember is,
yeah, Christy had had a few
therapists for many years
and had been very open and
experienced the benefits of that,
of going to therapy back
home in North Carolina,
and then out here when we moved out here,
and like all the stresses
and everything associated with that.
Therapy re-entered her life.
And we always had a
really positive view of it
because she had a very positive
and helpful experience with it.
And of course, we're talking to Jessie.
She's having positive experiences.
And then you get on board,
and you start having positive experiences.
And I was always very open to it,
but I think in a similar
way that you're describing,
it was, well, I'll say
that I started going
because Christy kept encouraging me,
and I was benefiting from hearing
from how everybody else is
benefiting from therapy.
So I felt like I was
getting therapy by proxy.
And I was, I've made jokes about that,
but in a way to acknowledge that like,
I'm warming up to this.
I wasn't opposed to it,
but I didn't feel like
I had an urgent need
to go to therapy,
like to run there to
fix a specific problem.
I didn't think that I had any
problems that needed therapy.
Meanwhile.
I was wrong.
Meanwhile, I mean, we never,
I don't know if we've
ever talked about this,
but meanwhile, like me, and Jesse,
and Christy would talk about,
well, when is Link gonna go to therapy?
Yeah, and sometimes I will be there.
But like, it's like-
So, it wasn't weird.
It wasn't like, when do we
intervene, I don't think.
You can't really talk to someone.
You had to let somebody come
to that decision on their own.
I would say that for anybody who thinks
that somebody in your life needs to go,
or you've experienced something,
and you're like, ah, man,
I wish that they could experience this.
Right.
You can't force them into it.
Well, your spouse can kinda do that.
Yeah.
Depending on the nature
of your relationship.
It became more of like,
I'm going to do this.
I have plans to do this,
but they're not, it's not
pressing, and it's not imminent.
So I'm gonna just keep back burnering it
for probably a couple of years.
In the meantime, I would read books,
a lot of the books that
Christy was reading
of the like introspective
self-help, self-discovery variety,
like stuff that she would be
recommended by her therapist
or that she would take to therapy.
So it was like an extension of that.
I would read those books,
and I would start to feel
the benefits of that.
And so I think the thing
that got me over the hump was
I, as a result of my
spiritual deconstruction,
and my ongoing spiritual journey,
and really coming to
grips with my priority of,
in doing the work, as they say,
like really invest in myself,
and understanding myself,
discovering more,
and just, I knew there
were things in my past
that affect me now,
and I was fascinated by that,
and I knew I could benefit from it.
So when I started going, it was like,
I know I experienced a lot of anxiety,
and I do want help with that.
There was like an opening meeting.
The way that I found my
therapist was on like
psychology.com.
They have, you can search
for somebody locally,
and you can read reviews.
And there was an initial
interview process.
Which if you want to,
you can tell how you met your therapist.
But with mine it was like,
I didn't have a personal recommendation.
I just had an interview
meeting phone call.
And I remember in that meeting,
I kinda just laid it all out.
I was like, I wanna send
a message that like,
I'm an open book and I'm all in for
however I can benefit from this.
And I know that I deal with anxiety,
and I know that I have things in my past.
When it came to the anxiety-
But it felt more like
an improvement thing,
not a fixing thing, or not a
help, please help me thing,
was I think my mindset going in, honestly.
'Cause when it comes to
the anxiety element of it,
like, would you have considered yourself,
like what level of anxiety would you,
if somebody was like on
a scale of one to 10,
how much anxiety do you have?
How would you have described that?
I would say that I'm able
to manage it at like a six
is what I would say at the time.
And six, well-
Maybe a five.
Maybe I would have said five or six.
I guess what I'm saying is-
And then it spikes.
Ultimately like if your
baseline level of anxiety
is self-assessed at a six out of 10-
Yeah.
I'm no expert, but that's sort of like,
okay, I'm actually-
Well, because I dealt with that so long,
I was kinda, it just kinda-
That's just, that's what everybody says.
Feels like a normal.
But I remember going to the cardiologist
back when Christy and
I were first married,
and I worked as an engineer at IBM.
And every day I'd come home
and lay down on the couch
and just to chill out.
And then my heart would
just be like skipping beats
and like jumping out of my chest.
Sometimes I would wake up
in the middle of the night
with like those heart
palpitations or whatever.
I don't know if that's the official title,
but like, and I talk.
I remember I talked,
I told my therapist very
early on about that.
And I was like, that was 20 years ago.
Yeah.
But I knew that it was stress.
At least I really hoped that it was stress
because when I sent in the
EKG readings, the tech said,
yeah, this just looks
like you're stressed out,
and then so I never
followed up with a doctor.
And you're like, oh, of
course I can, handle that.
But I kinda knew.
And then I would,
I developed various coping
mechanisms over the years
and just kind of felt like
I was putting the anxiety
in its place.
But there's also, I think
there's also a thing-
So then only in certain
times would my heart rate,
heart start to flutter like that
when I was in a really stressful zone.
I mean, I think, and I'm not
trying to generalize here,
but I do think I am going to generalize.
So I'm just, I guess I'm just giving
a generalization disclaimer.
That in my experience,
there are a lot of men who,
based on like certain cultural
pressures and expectations,
especially if they are in
a relationship with a woman
who is already kind of addressing
her mental and emotional health,
I think there's a resistance.
There's a resistance to
be like, I got, I feel,
oh, I mean, I gotta be the one
that's got it together, man.
Like, and so even if you would-
It may be that.
Assess yourself
at a six out of 10 of
like a baseline anxiety-
I got it under control.
You're like, I got it under control.
Like I'm not about to explode.
I'm a safe person.
But, and so then you kinda say,
but she's really the one that needs help,
and she's getting the help that she needs.
Which is very-
And I would've never said that.
I'm just saying that there was a-
Subconscious.
Subconscious thought that just,
I thought that that's just the way
that it was supposed to work.
I agree with that experience.
I relate to that,
and I think that it
wasn't fair to our wives
to like put them in that box as like,
okay, you're the ones that
need therapy 'cause you have.
What I think was going on
was that they were actually
much more in touch with what
was going on inside of them,
and much more willing to seek help for it
when we were just out of touch with it.
And I just kinda put it in this box,
the physical evidence that
there's something going on
deep with inside of me
that I need to wrestle with
and deal with,
and that's why it looked different.
And I could say, well,
that's what I would describe.
Well, Christy situation,
or she's the one who needs help,
because that's what it looks like.
But really what she was
demonstrating is an openness
and an in touchness with herself.
And I didn't realize that, for me,
it was a closed off, not
willing to go there thing.
And I just chalked it up to differences.
And I think that-
And needs.
Unintentionally, there's
this amplification effect
that you actually make the,
whatever it is that your partner
or your friend is
dealing with more intense
by not addressing your own problems.
Right, so if you're somebody
who's walking around,
I mean, obviously I got my own-
You mean comparing, like-
Well, no, no, I'm just saying.
So-and-so's worse than me.
If you're going around
a six out of 10 anxiety,
based level anxiety, you're
not the best person to be,
to rely on for someone who's
going through those issues.
You can even exacerbate the
anxiety that she's dealing with.
I know that I did that for Jessie.
As someone who wasn't
processing my emotions
in a healthy way, I was
not the best resource.
And again, I don't wanna get into like
codependent situation.
What I'm saying is that
if you actually want to be
the healthiest partner to your partner
who is having their own issues,
dealing with your own shit
is one way to address that.
But when you're like,
I don't have anything,
I don't have anything to deal with,
then you can actually
create more of a burden
for your partner who's already
dealing with their own stuff.
So I went in with this like
optimization self-improvement,
become my best self kind of thing.
And I was willing to go to dark places
in order to get there,
but I was also like, how dark can it be?
Really?
And so,
I did bring everything I had to it,
but there's a little bit of a dance,
'cause you have to ease into
it because it's a relationship.
This is a complete stranger
with qualifications and reviews.
So this dude's checked out,
and I feel like we're starting
off on a good foundation,
but you gotta build on that.
And you gotta talk about yourself,
and like you don't expect immediate.
I'm learning that like, okay,
I don't wanna expect
like immediate results.
I gotta give this some
time and let this blossom.
Then the pandemic hit,
and I lot of, I mean,
therapy for me evolved
into crisis management,
like the crisis of the pandemic
and all the pressures that we then,
that you mentioned earlier,
filtered through that.
Leading a company and
being a resource for my,
loving my family became
a week to week crisis.
I've talked about Christy's
health challenges,
and I'm so grateful that I
had gotten in under the wire,
and we had met in person
a few times, that then,
and I had gotten a slot with
this guy so that I could then,
when the really started hitting the fan,
and boy, was it hitting the fan
for the majority of that year,
every week was just help
me hold this together,
I think is what I brought to our meetings.
Now this has happened.
How do I deal with this?
How do I respond?
So it was kind of, it was
a survival type thing.
And I've described the low
points and all those challenges.
So I don't wanna go into that,
but that really impacted the
tenor of what therapy became
for me for that entire time.
And then there was,
and then when things are better,
or like when the light shines,
when the clouds clear for a little bit,
and the light shines through,
I remember there being a few sessions
where it was actually about
kinda living in that moment of,
I'd walked through all
of these difficult things
and anticipated more,
but with this person,
that then it was kind of
a, it was a sweet session
when we could just kind of celebrate it.
And so I discovered that like
that was a different facet of therapy.
Like that the relationship paid off,
and it could be a positive
celebration of moments of growth
or just of survival.
But I'm painting a picture
of us not really getting back
to that like deeper inner work
that was like the thing that I
thought I was signing up for.
Because getting through the
day, and the next night,
and the next week was kind of all that
I had the capacity to focus on.
So I would say that described
a phase of therapy for me.
And I'm interested if you see
it that way or how you see it,
but then I'll say there's a next phase
that I'm kind of in now,
which is really great news that like,
there's been enough space between crises
that I can start to say,
what are some deeper
things that I wanna work on
or places I wanna go?
But it wasn't without a
very specific challenge
that related to therapy
itself that I'll get into.
But I wanted to hand it back over to you
in terms of like how
you see the trajectory
of building that relationship,
and has it gone through phases?
So my therapist was
Jessie's therapists first.
Okay.
And also my boys had been
to see him initially.
Actually the thing that
was the impetus was
kinda recognizing that Shepherd had ADHD,
and that was, and somebody recommended
who is now basically our
therapist that everyone can see.
I mean, Jesse and I are the ones
that see him regularly, but.
So he had a lot of
insight into our family.
And I think, and again, not
every therapist will do that.
And it was a long process,
and there's people have
different opinions about
whether or not a therapist
should serve a couple
or a family in that way.
For us, it's a really good circumstance.
I don't think I would
recommend it for everybody.
But one of the things that did is
there was a level of trust and connection.
And I think actually the
first time I met my therapist
was in a couple session with Jesse there.
And that was the introduction to like,
oh, this is the guy that she's
been talking about for years,
and now I know who he is.
And so that first session
was like talking to somebody
that I already knew.
I think, when that's
the way that it starts,
and of course, if your wife
has been going to a therapist,
and your wife has been
talking about you in therapy-
Yeah.
You come as a, there's a
narrative attached to you.
Right? Which could be a negative thing.
But I think that Jesse was very fair
in the way that she kind
of described the things
that I dealt with.
But then I immediately
confirmed all those things
while meeting.
And again, my main issue,
the sort of the, the main
sort of ongoing thing
that is my struggle is
the fact that I tend to
intellectualize and
rationalize my emotions
versus just experiencing them, right?
So something comes in experientially,
and there's a natural, emotional
response to that thing,
whether it be sadness, or anger, whatever.
And if it's an inconvenient emotion,
I think I've always seen
myself as a very self-reliant,
super dependable.
Like you can put me through
basically any circumstance,
and I'm gonna be the one
person that's still standing.
Right?
It's a pride thing.
I don't know what it is,
but I've, like give me
something else to do.
I will not break.
Give me a new challenge.
I will succeed at it.
And so negative emotions feel
like wastes of time for me.
Right? Being sad about something.
Well, that's like, who's got?
Ain't nobody got time for
that. You know what I mean?
And so what you end up doing is
if there's something
that's genuinely difficult
for me to deal with that should result in
an outpouring of grief, or
sadness, frustration, whatever,
I will immediately, and
I'm very skilled at this,
refrain that circumstance to remind myself
that it's actually not that bad.
Like this is not that bad.
Lots of people have it worse than you.
Like you can actually
easily get to over here
and see the bright side of this,
and see the optimistic side,
and see the future of
where this thing could go.
And I immediately just move to the side,
and I get on that track.
And there's a lot of benefit in that
when it comes to like being successful
in capitalistic society, right?
And so I have experienced a
tremendous amount of success
in one sense
because of my tendency to
not let myself feel things
and just to kind of.
But what was happening over time is that
if you continue to do that,
those emotions are going
somewhere to be processed.
Usually if it's a sadness
that you're dealing with,
then it will be an outburst of anger.
It will be a short temper, which
I definitely have at times.
And it will be like, oh,
you went from zero to 100.
Like where did that come from?
The kids came in and did something,
and you snapped at him immediately.
Like what was?
A lot of that comes from not processing
and letting myself feel things.
So that's my main issue.
There's a lot of other issues,
but I'm saying that that's
the main sort of emotional
sort of misfire that
happens repeatedly with me.
And so-
And that's something that you discovered.
You became acquainted with it in therapy.
'Cause what I would have told you,
and what I would have told Jesse
is I would have just told you
the positive side of that thing.
I would be like, I'm kind of a stoic guy.
Like I can get very
enthusiastic about things,
and it's not like I don't cry.
Like I said, I'll cry
at Hallmark commercials.
But, and then when my
therapist explained to me,
he was like, well, the reason you do that
is because you're very
willing to feel emotions
for other people.
Like if I go to a wedding,
I don't care if I know
the people, I'm gonna cry.
If I go to a funeral,
I'll most likely cry.
But if I am experiencing
something, very rarely will I cry.
If it's something that's an emotion
that I'm the target of it,
and I'm the one who's
supposed to feel sadness,
I'll deflect it, and I'll save it.
You put it over here in a little jar.
It's building up.
That jar has gotta be emptied somehow.
It's either gonna come out as anger,
or it's gonna come out as
emotion for someone else.
I just always was like,
I never, had never sorted
through any of this stuff.
I was just like, I'm like my dad.
I'm just like, I'm super dependable.
I'm not the emotional person in the room.
Like, I'm not gonna
take any of your energy.
Like if you're in a relationship with me,
if you're working with me,
we're never going to have
to stop to accommodate me.
Like I'm not that guy.
And so I just was like, and
that's what makes me great.
You know what I'm saying?
But what my therapist was beginning to,
well, and Jesse was
saying things about it.
Like, well, you just,
you're not just letting
yourself feel this.
You're not opening yourself up to this.
It was just a couple of
meetings as I explained.
He was like, tell me about yourself.
I mean, the first few meetings
were talking about my upbringing,
talking about the way I see things.
And I'm presenting
myself in a certain way,
and I wasn't trying to present
a good picture of myself.
I was like, I know I need something
because I mean, I've got all
this physical stuff happening.
I don't really understand what it is
'cause I don't have the
language to talk about this.
But, and my therapist is a
very good friend now as well.
Right?
So he can say, he just
tells me like it is.
And sometimes-
Hold on, let's not skip ahead though.
So, but early on you were
telling about yourself,
and then you were unpacking these things,
and he was helping you
come to these realizations
that you've just shared.
Yeah, but like, what I'm getting at is,
there was an immediate
relational connection.
So I'm not just saying he's a friend now.
There's an immediate sort
of relational connection,
which is not necessarily
normal or expected.
I will just say that. It
just worked out that way.
And I don't even think it's
necessary, to be clear,
but in my situation, it was great.
But like, I specifically remember a time
where I would like explain
something, and he just laughed.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Because he was observing how adept I was
at moving myself out away from like,
you get on the uncomfortable
peak of an emotion,
and you immediately dodge it.
And he could just observe that happening,
and he would be like, no, no, no, stop.
Let's stay there with this thing.
Where do you feel it?
Like where physically?
And like the first time he asked me
where I felt something
physically, I laughed at him.
Because I was just like, man,
what does that even mean?
Where do I feel it?
Like I can't even tell you what I feel,
much less where I feel it.
Yeah.
But I've since, we'll get into it later
like what I've actually learned
and how I've applied that,
but that was kinda my
initial experience was like,
immediately kinda understanding
what the challenge was
and having it explained to me in a.
And this is my tendency is I'm gonna like
try to like academically
define what it was.
And so right from the
beginning, I was like,
oh, this is what's wrong with me.
So this is the thing that
I need to start fixing.
That happened really quickly.
The fixing-
Then what?
The fixing is a different process.
Well, so I do a session,
I've consistently done every
other week, not weekly.
For an hour and a half instead of an hour.
Well, yeah, like a double session.
So I guess it ends up being
the same amount of time
as if I was doing it every single week.
But, and it's actually gotten
a little bit shorter recently,
in the past year or so.
It's pretty much just a single
session every other week.
Did it, when I described
like the crisis thing,
like, I mean, are there
times when you're like,
this happened or there's a crisis?
Yeah, well, every session-
And it's external.
It's an external crisis.
Well, yeah, usually-
Obviously there's an internal component.
It usually starts with that, yeah.
Yeah, I, and I still do this.
It's still my tendency,
but I will start off a
session kinda telling him
everything that's kinda going
on in no particular order.
I don't take, I don't have an agenda.
I don't really think about it
until I see him on the call.
And then I'm just like,
I just start going,
and I just start talking.
And the things that are the heaviest
and feel like the biggest sort
of burden are the things that
become very obvious
very quickly as I talk.
And then he'll kind of rewind.
Let's go back to this,
and then we'll kinda talk about that.
And again, it's a subtle process
of just getting me to actually
understand what it is that I'm feeling.
It's pretty simple with me
because the issue is so severe.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm sure there's other things
to continue to deal with,
but because the tendency
is to just reframe,
redefine, and cope versus
feel, it's really just like,
all right, let's talk about that.
Let's see what you're feeling.
And so one of the things that,
I know we're gonna talk a little bit about
how you gauge your own progress.
So I don't wanna say that now,
but because the issue is
kinda singular for me,
and yes, it will be like,
we're having particular issue.
And again, 'cause he
knows our family so well,
he might be like, well, I already know
the issue that so-and-so is dealing with.
Now, he doesn't tell me anything.
There's privacy. It's
a little complicated.
But like he, if I had to say,
well, Jessie's going through
this thing right now,
or Locke's going through
he already has insight into that
'cause he's already
talked to them about it.
Which again, for me,
has been a great benefit
because you got somebody
who understands the dynamics
on both sides of the situation.
So there are times when
you're walking through
like processing a crisis,
but the general mode for
you is like a continual,
an exercise of bringing
your emotions to the table
and processing things on
a level, on that level,
like instead of just
the way that you would
left to your own devices pre-therapy.
Yeah, it's just kind of
sorting through all that stuff.
Okay.
Because, it's interesting
because there's a difference
between vulnerability and
emotional vulnerability.
I'm actually a really vulnerable
person in terms of like,
I'm not a secretive, protective person.
If I meet you on the subway,
which I don't go on the subway
'cause I'm in Los Angeles.
We call it a Metro, and I
don't usually take that.
But I could have a
conversation with somebody,
and immediately get into
like some deep stuff
and be very personally
disclosing about myself,
my issues, et cetera.
Yeah, you can share things.
Yeah.
Factually.
And I'm a very, I'm a
very introspective person.
Meaning that I'm willing
to look at myself,
and analyze my actions,
et cetera, et cetera.
But those are not substitutes
for emotional vulnerability.
Again, yes, I've cried on
this podcast, whatever.
But what I'm talking about is just like
getting to a place where
I give myself permission
to feel something.
Like it's okay, you
can stop and feel this.
Like no task is gonna be left aside.
Or it's okay for this person
to see you in this state.
So I wanna, 'cause those
issues can get conflated
pretty easily.
Well, as an aside,
I think we're both very vulnerable here,
but there are things that we've decided
that we're comfortable sharing,
but there's moments when
we might be experiencing
something on an emotional level.
Like if we tear up or
cry about something here,
that happens much more rarely.
It's a different type of vulnerability.
So even if you look at it here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
See, the reason why I'm asking
like the questions of like,
how you go about therapy
and how you view it,
is because I feel like,
even though it's been almost two years
for me, I'm still just getting started
because there was so much
acute crisis to deal with.
And there was definitely,
I mean, I'm not saying that
there weren't times when like
we've made connections between my past
and how that impacts me now,
or what's going on inside of me.
And definitely I've been
processing the emotional aspects
of the crisis that I'm going through
and finding it as a resource.
I do tend to overanalyze everything.
And so at certain points I
would describe therapy as,
you know what I feel like if
I were just talking to a wall,
and I was disciplined enough
to like verbally process
to that wall every week for an hour.
And then kind of,
that I would come to a lot
of the same conclusions.
Like that's probably not true.
That says a lot about your therapist.
I'm just kidding.
It says a lot about me, right?
I understand exactly.
I mean, I'm just being honest
that sometimes it feels that way
'cause it's like, well,
how much did he say?
I can talk a lot.
I can get, you know I can get going,
and I am such a verbal processor,
that like hearing myself is a huge part
of the process for me.
And on the skeptical side, I'm like,
yeah, he only asked me
three questions, but-
How much am I paying him?
And how much am I paying him?
But on the other side it's,
those are some pivotal questions.
And those moments when
I stopped, and thought,
and answered to the question,
probably redirected the whole conversation
in a way that the wall wouldn't.
But I'm just being honest and saying-
If it's a Tesla wall, I don't know.
I always like feel that way.
But I've noticed in the points
when there's not something
that like I feel like I am,
need to run to someone for help,
that I'm drowning in some way,
or that I want to help
somebody else that I love,
or something.
If there's not an emergency
and the session's coming up,
I just really started noticing
the amount of trepidation
that I would bring to it.
And this started happening,
I think, pretty early.
Like I actually, I went
through a period of time
in the first year where I
would jot down on my phone,
like a sentence or two
from the therapy session.
And I went back and looked,
and I realized that like a
year ago this was happening.
Like we had gone through a lot of things.
And like, it was one of those,
like the clouds had cleared moment.
And I jotted down that I was just,
I approached the sessions
with so much trepidation
because I did not know what
I wanted to talk about.
And then I noticed over the past few,
and by the way, when that happened,
I remember I canceled an appointment.
And then it was, and then
the next week I like,
I wanted to cancel again.
And so, I ended up talking
about it a little bit
instead of canceling the.
I like, I felt like I confessed it.
I was like, listen, I
canceled on you last week
because I was just too
afraid to show up and not.
And the unknown just was too much for me.
I didn't know what I wanted to talk about.
And then a lot of shit hit
the fan again, or I guess,
because over the last few weeks,
maybe months, it's come up again.
And I guess it's a good sign
that like, I have the room.
I have the head space to
say, I'm not drowning here.
I'm not afraid.
I'm not desperate for help
about a specific thing.
But my mind immediately goes to, now what?
That's how I know therapy.
So going back to that first place of like,
I'm gonna just start working
on some like longer term,
or deeper issues, shadow work type stuff,
the real sexy, hard stuff.
Instead, my mind, I would
just get frozen with,
I don't know what to say.
And I would get so stressed out
like five, six days in advance.
And I would notice the moment
that I would come up with
something, I'd feel relief.
And I would, I'd realize that like,
this is what I felt in college
every time I had an assignment.
Until I could finish the assignment
or develop a plan that I
knew I could finish it,
it would drive me nuts.
And I started to think,
this might be a good thing
to talk about in therapy.
Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
But you know-
But, so my question is,
because again, like what
I'm hearing, as your friend,
as you say these things,
is just like, yes,
the reason that you should be in therapy
is the, it being evidenced
in the way that you approach therapy.
Yeah.
And so when you take
this to your therapist,
what do you feel?
Do you feel like there are some?
And again, I understand
it's not about necessarily.
You're not necessarily paying
them for their insights,
so to speak.
It is like paying for time to process,
which everybody needs,
but they are trained professionals.
So do you feel like when you take that-
A year ago when I took it to him,
he was like, you know what,
I want you to feel like you can come with
absolutely blank slate,
not knowing anything.
Some of the best sessions
I have with people
are when they have no clue
what we're going to talk about.
And they still show up.
And he encouraged me to think about it as
I'm prioritizing myself
and something that I need.
This is me time that's protected.
And he didn't say, you're
not performing for me,
or we didn't really, he just
reassured me at the time.
It was like, you know what?
You don't have to come up with anything.
I got this.
I can handle this.
And I could not bring myself
to believe him in action.
It was difficult.
And then more shit hit the fan,
and I had stuff that I
felt like was urgent,
and it was.
So, and then it kinda, again,
it moved to the back burner,
but I realized that was a year ago.
That was October that I
put that in my journal,
my phone journal.
So a few weeks ago, a few sessions ago,
I brought it up again.
And I was like, this is still happening.
I'm having such a difficult time.
I don't know what my hangup is.
We started to explore like,
well, I wanna make sure it's
worth my time and my money.
I wanna, am I afraid that
I'm not demonstrating,
that I'm not making the most of this,
that I'm not bringing enough to this,
and my therapist knows it?
And I'm telling him
this stuff at that time.
And I'm realizing that
there's definitely barriers
there for me to accepting
that as a place that is,
that's a nonjudgmental zone.
Because there's a lot of things going on,
but one of the things
that I realized was that
I just assume that he is analyzing me
in the same way that I'm
analyzing the session and myself.
And control is obviously
a big thing for me
that I'm working on,
and I see it at play here.
It's like, when I don't feel
like I can, I have plans,
meaning that I have control
over where the therapy starts,
so then I know when I've gotten to it,
when I've gotten to the answer,
when I've made the most of the session,
when I've gotten my
money and time's worth,
when I've gotten, when I've demonstrated
that I'm willing to make progress
because I actually have made progress.
'Cause I brought a starting point,
and then there was some
sort of conclusion.
I definitely found myself
towards the end of a session.
I would look at the clock
throughout the session
and realize, okay, I'm halfway through.
There's something else
I wanted to talk about
so I'm gonna get to that now.
I would very much control everything
in order to try to feel okay about it.
And then at the end, if it went well,
I would always, I realized that
I would thank my therapist.
I don't know if this seems weird.
Because I wanted to acknowledge to him
kind of in like a code that
like, yes, you helped me.
I got what I needed out of this.
It's like kinda giving him a review,
and demonstrating that I've made progress.
And I did.
So all of these things,
I'm starting to realize,
as we're having the conversation
about how freaking difficult it is for me,
and how much I put on myself
and bring into therapy
just because it's therapy,
or what I think it should be in my mind.
And then I realized that like, I haven't,
before going to therapy
in this environment,
like the way that we would
do it before is we would,
I would go visit.
I would have a counselor,
which would normally be my church pastor.
And I knew that that was
not a judgment free zone.
Like I always knew that innately.
There was like, a pastor
was always comparing,
at least in my mind, comparing my,
like whatever I was confessing.
And again, I never confessed
to a Catholic priest.
It wasn't like that.
I never went into the closet
with the Catholic priest.
Just the Protestant
guy would be comparing,
well this is, comparing my point of view
and my actions to the morals of the Bible,
and then saying, okay, well, this is what,
this is how you need to change.
This is what you need to repent of.
This is where you're in sin,
and this is where you need
to get right with God, right?
It was an implied place of judgment,
the exact opposite of what
therapy is supposed to be.
Right?
And I-
Yeah.
And it's so difficult for me to believe
that he's not constantly judging me.
'Cause I'm like, aren't you
coming up with an assessment?
Don't you have like? Like what do you?
I've been talking to you for
almost, for a year and a half.
More like, what conclusions
are you drawing about me?
What do you know?
Did you ask him that?
Yeah.
He said a number of things that were like
made me feel, they were edifying.
But then he basically
said that I deal with,
I can't remember the term he used.
Basically like, I have anxiety.
And it seems, it's like,
well, maybe it seems obvious,
but and this was just a few weeks ago.
And I know, and I harness all
of my neurosis for comedy.
I am acquainted with it enough
to use it to my advantage
and also kinda laugh at myself.
But to hear the therapist
just kinda say it
in more of like a diagnosis kinda way,
it shook me up a little bit.
Because it was like, oh, I
don't just experience anxiety.
I have anxiety.
It felt different to me.
And I just uncovered a lot there,
but it's like-
There's a few things that come up for me
as you talk about this.
I mean, one is, the
conversation that you're having
with me right now about your therapy.
And you've done this a little bit,
but it definitely feels
like that's the conversation
that you should be
having with a therapist.
Now, like you said, you have
kind of done that, right?
Yeah.
Because the nature of
the way you're seeing it,
and the nature of the
conversation that we're having
about it is indicative
of what your work is
in the anxiety, and control,
and those things. Right?
Yeah.
I mean, if you feel like when
you asked him that question,
I mean, again, it's tough.
It's tough for me.
I don't, like I'm not here to evaluate
the effectiveness of your
particular therapist, right?
There's a part of me
that, in the way that like
Jesse had already told my therapist
a bunch of things about me.
Someone who's in relationship with you,
which is actually something
I wanna talk about
in terms of how I evaluate
what I've actually experienced in therapy
and what the benefit has been,
but also kinda understanding
what it is that your issues are,
are sometimes most eloquently articulated
by the people in your life.
Because I could have told you-
Yeah, I've gone to-
That your issues-
I've gone to therapy with Christy
and been able to provide my perspective,
that really kinda coalesced
some things for Christy.
It's like, I feel like if me and Christy
could sit down with your
therapist for one hour
and just be like, can we
just tell you some things
about Link?
'Cause I don't know if it's coming across
as he talks to you.
I don't know if he's
packaging it differently,
or he doesn't have a,
'cause no one has a great
self-assessment, right?
I don't have a great self-assessment, so.
But you're really, I
mean, I think you are,
and I'm totally cool with this,
that like you are questioning whether,
after all this time,
couldn't he have like,
couldn't he have gotten,
do I need a new therapist?
Well, well, no, I guess
what I'm saying is, is that,
okay, as I think back
on our life together,
first of all, there was a lot.
Like if you take our life
in sections really quickly,
and you take like growing up together,
I had absolutely no clue
that you were dealing with
so much anxiety.
I was not.
Like that was not.
Right.
Anxiety wasn't something
I was dealing with.
You were like nervous and shaken
up by all kinds of things,
and no one had any idea
that it was happening.
Your best friend had no
idea it was happening.
And then for most of our adult life,
I kind of dismissed a lot of your anxious.
First of all, it would
be like, yes, he's got.
Like once we started working
together, I was like,
oh, he's got a lot of control issues.
I see that.
And that is interesting in
like creative collaboration,
but it didn't feel like a mental problem
or like emotional problem.
It's just like, Link has control issues.
It's something that he
understands, I understand,
and we work it out.
But your anxiety was
something that I did not have
an understanding of.
I was just like, I know he's
stressed out, quote unquote,
because he's as busy as I am.
And I know what it feels
like to be this busy.
And I know what it feels like
to have this much pressure,
and have this many projects,
and this many employees,
and all these issues that
we're constantly dealing with.
Like, it's stressful as hell.
So, and we do everything side-by-side.
So I know that you're stressed out,
but the anxiety that you bring to
like every type of experience,
not just the stressful things,
is something that I
didn't have a language for
until I started going to therapy,
and we started like talking
about all this stuff, right?
And so I've come to understand like,
oh, like Link is running
really, really hot.
Yeah.
That baseline anxiety
that you're talking about.
And now, okay, I see it come out
in some of the things
that he says and does.
It's like, oh, that's coming out
because he's so anxious
about this thing right now.
And so to me, and I'm not saying,
I mean, he's told you that
you deal with anxiety.
I'm not saying he's a bad therapist,
but I'm just like, okay,
we're two years in,
and he's like saying that like, no, man,
like, this is your, this
is an issue that like is
very consequential in your life.
Do you know what I mean?
And so I just want, I
mean, I guess I'm just,
what I want him to do is-
I have a hard time judging my therapist
'cause I'm just constantly judging myself.
No, I understand that.
And we do talk about those things,
and we do, and so it's like assignments.
Like think back on
memories from your child,
like from your childhood.
Let's explore like your
family life growing up.
Like okay, your dad wasn't there.
Then your stepdad wasn't there.
And this is how you
interacted with your mom.
It's like, we do talk about those things,
and it does, and it has shed
light on my impulse to control
and the roots of my anxiety.
Right, and the control
being the thing that is,
you're trying to get hold of
the anxiety with the control.
Right?
Yes.
I didn't even, we talked about this today.
I didn't even realize
until like six months ago
that a lot of the things
you told me in situations
where you were just vocalizing
something to yourself,
but you were telling me
because I'm with you.
You know what I'm saying?
And then I'm like, oh, he does that a lot.
Like, he's like, now don't
forget to make the most of this.
Or you say something to me, and I'm like.
And for years I was always just like,
yeah, you're right, man.
It's like I didn't
really need to hear that,
but you're right in what you just said.
All of a sudden it hit me.
I was like, oh, he's
self-soothing right now
by saying this thing to me.
And so I guess what I'm saying is this.
I just wanna sit down with
your therapist and be like,
'cause I wanna hear him talk,
and I want to know like, do
you really understand this guy?
Do you understand him?
I mean, I do think that my work is
like understanding what I'm so afraid of.
And I think that, I don't,
it's, do I need a new therapist?
Listen.
It's really hard.
I mean, I have,
I mean, Christy's has been
through different therapist.
It's very common.
Other people that I know have been,
most people that I've talked to
that I know really closely about therapy
have been to multiple therapists.
And sometimes they've gone back.
Just to know what they
may have been missing.
Well-
So I actually feel like-
If you were to ask-
And I feel like I would
like to start over anyway.
It's like something about the way that it,
again, we talk about it.
We talk about two weeks
ago, we have so much in.
So it's an opportunity to
kinda change the trajectory
to not be so crisis oriented.
We talked about that specifically,
and that's why we got into the,
reflect more on your past, and
we can unpack some of that,
and talk about this impulse to control.
Like, this is where
we've talked about going.
But I do wonder, there is
a part of me that's like,
I feel like I gotta have somebody to,
I gotta have a different
experience with a different person
to compare it to.
Yeah, I mean, I can't advise you,
and I'm just, I guess-
Because I, but I think the thing
that I feel like I'm missing is like,
I would, I just anticipated
that I would be breaking down
left and right in therapy.
I mean, I just don't.
I've got a shit ton of issues,
but it's not like,
I don't think I have the
issue you're talking about
where I'm not gonna like
weep about my own emotion,
let that emotion out.
You know?
I actually think that I,
that's not what I thought
I was signing up for.
I thought I was signing
up for crying a lot.
And you know-
And because I haven't,
and I just feel like,
I feel like that's a reason to look for,
see if another therapist
can get me to cry more,
because I thought that
was gonna be part of it.
That's an outward sign for me
that I'm getting somewhere.
And it may be.
I mean, as somebody who,
just to put things into perspective,
as somebody who's been
going to therapy since 2017,
specifically focusing on
being able to feel things
and process things, I still haven't cried.
And my wife just laughs at me.
I mean, not in jest,
but just because she's
like, I cry every damn time.
But do you think that I would?
Listen, I'm not-
At least a few times.
Like, I want a breakthrough,
I guess is what I'm saying.
Here's what I'll say.
I wanna be really hesitant to like,
'cause I'm not a
professional by any means.
Well, I know that.
It's just.
I know how to filter your advice.
In comparing it to my experience
where the way that I would categorize,
the way I would characterize
what happened with me is
very, very quickly we got to the root.
And now, when we got to the root,
we saw that the root was
really thick, and really deep,
and splayed out in many different areas.
So it's not like just
identifying the issue solves it
because I still have all the tendencies,
but it didn't take, it took two
sessions to get to the root,
not two years to get to the root.
Yeah, and like, I feel like we're like,
we're certainly digging
into in the right place,
but, and there's reasons why
maybe it's taking this long
to get back to it.
But I feel like that I can't
continue the route analogy
in talking about the
point I'm trying to make.
What is the point I'm trying to make?
Well, okay.
I'll talk a little bit
about, because I recent-
Oh, I know what I was trying to say.
We're looking in the right place,
like saying, this is
the root of the issue.
And I'm envious of the way that like,
now you kinda know, well, I'm envious.
I feel like you've
described an assignment.
Like you bring the therapy your life,
and then you make sure
that you're processing it
on a level that you haven't been able to
until therapy unlocked that
for you, an emotional level.
So the protocol seems clear to me.
Again, it's a plan.
I feel like,
and so is my exercise to find someone new
who can give me that breakthrough,
and then filter every
experience that I have
through the trauma that
I've endured as a child,
that then is making me
wanting to control everything
to soothe it,
or is my exercise that and
also letting go of the control
of needing a plan to get
there, and analyzing-
That's what makes it
really complicated for you.
And in a different way, again,
because I like to present
myself as having it together,
and I do it unconsciously.
Again, I don't know.
Now, I'm not gonna get
into what I've explored
specifically about my childhood
that kind of potentially
led me to a place that,
this is the way that I cope with things.
But because I present as
someone who's got it together,
as a default,
sometimes it takes 30
minutes of talking in therapy
to begin to break through the shell
'cause I'm doing it
without even knowing it.
Just like, I think things
are going pretty good,
but they're not.
Like and they may be externally,
but like in here,
no, there's something
that you're not really.
I gotta bring that out.
So yeah, there is this, I'm constantly.
What I'm saying is that my
issue does directly impact
the way that I do therapy.
So I'm not saying that like,
every time I start a therapy
session, I'm like, here we go.
I know what the work is. Let's do it.
No, the work is directly related
into the way that I approach
therapy in a very similar way,
just a different issue.
But I feel like my therapist is so attuned
to that being the problem
that he will just be like,
okay, let's stop a second.
Now, do you see what you did there?
You've been talking about
this for this much time,
and you see how quickly
you moved to this thing.
But what about this thing?
And so, because he's like,
I'm dealing with a guy,
if it was like he was a
coach, and it was just like,
the thing this guy can't do
is he can't go to his left.
Right.
Then he would be-
See, there's a level of authority
that I'm envious of that too,
because I feel like-
You don't feel like he's assertive enough.
Yeah.
Like he's like stop.
When you said that, could that mean this?
It's like, I just don't.
I feel like it's all up to me.
It's like, he's gonna answer.
He's gonna ask a question,
and he's gonna, what else am I gonna say?
Now what am I gonna say to the wall?
The fact that you've now
referred to him as a wall
multiple times, maybe.
Listen, I don't want, again,
everybody's experience is different,
but because there's a
question in your mind-
But I think it's a style thing.
I don't think it's a criticism
of him as much as like,
am I discovering what I need?
And 'cause it's just a relationship.
So it's the style, right?
The therapist is a person.
So I just, I'm really feeling like
I'm wanna try somebody else
just because it's just a fit.
It's a style. It's a-
You wanna go to my therapist too?
No, that would be unethical.
At some point, the circle
has to stop expanding.
I mean, could it be a handoff?
Like-
Maybe you take the weeks
that I'm not there.
No, again, this is two very,
very non-professional guys
talking about therapy,
but I think, the only thing
that I want to affirm is that
I don't think it's wrong to think,
should I just, could I
try something else out?
I know it's not wrong,
and I know that they do it all the time.
Yeah.
And, but it's like, I get hung up on it.
And I'm definitely thinking
that I'm not gonna tell him.
I'm just gonna get a second
therapist at the same time.
Wow.
I don't know how I feel about that.
I should be able to tell him.
He's my therapist.
Yeah, I think-
But it's like, hey, I'm
breaking up with you
for a little time until I change my mind
and realized that the
grass wasn't greener,
and then I'll come back to you.
He knows all of that.
It happens all the time, right?
I can just be like, 'cause-
I think you have to
talk to him about this.
The temptation is,
I'll just go to every other week,
and then I can hedge with somebody else.
I think the whole point is, is that-
I gotta build the other person back up
while I taper the other guy off.
Well, I feel like-
I don't wanna be left in a lurch.
This is the thing I was kinda
getting at earlier is that
I feel like there's the real narrative
that's happening in here,
and then there's the curated narrative
that you bring to your therapist.
And I think that, and I do the same thing.
But the-
I didn't know you were saying that.
But what I'm, 'cause no,
'cause I'm performative
in a different way, right?
I'm definitely performative. Okay.
But you're-
My performative is that
I'm getting, I'm being-
You're trying to control it,
and get the most out of it,
and make it the best possible session.
I'm just trying to appear
like I got it together.
Yeah.
Even if I don't.
But they're both performative
in a certain way.
So the thing that he breaks me out of is
the curated narrative.
And either you gotta break yourself
out of the curated narrative or-
Or if I don't have a curated narrative,
whatever it is, I just
want to have more of a,
I think his style is more
like raise a question,
and then it's self-discovery,
but it's not a conversation.
We're not batting ideas back and forth.
Well, and you know-
And I kinda want a little more of that.
This is a way that we tell
people who work for us
and work with us this all the time.
Because if there's anything that we are,
we have very much in common in
the way we work with people,
is we invite collaboration
really intensely.
And we tell people, when we
get ready to work on a project,
we say, listen, you can't offend us,
and we don't hold any ideas sacred.
If you don't like something,
you should tell us
because that's how we work.
And listen, if you step back,
and you make it a light touch thing,
and you don't ever voice your opinion,
we will bowl over you
because we have so much
intense creative energy.
Now, I actually think
we kind of function
relationships in this way.
And so I think what
you're asking, it's like-
When I have something to bring to therapy-
You want him to-
I bowl over. I talk to the wall.
Yeah, you want him to reach out
and grab you by the collar.
Yeah.
So to speak.
And again, I feel like
my therapist does that
in the most respectful,
friendly way possible,
but he just kinda is ready to,
when he smells bullshit,
he says, I smell bullshit.
You know what I mean?
I don't know what he need to smell.
Maybe there's a different scent for me,
a different stink than bullshit.
But yeah, it's not, whatever that is,
I would like to be-
So I think you gotta talk to him,
and I think you gotta say that I'm just,
this is how I feel.
And what I want to do is
maybe meet with someone else
just 'cause I just don't have anything,
I don't have any sort of
connection to compare this to,
and see what he says.
And then I'm starting over.
It's like, that's why I haven't done it.
And that's when things go better,
and I have that, like I don't
have anything to talk about,
I'm like, I'll just, I'll stretch it out.
I'll just meet every other week.
We'll try that out.
Maybe I don't need therapy.
I start to tell myself that stuff.
Okay.
And then I know what-
This is what I wanted to talk about
because I started thinking
the same thing, okay?
And I actually asked Jesse
when we were getting
ready for this episode.
I was like, I feel like I
understand what my problem is,
and I understand what I'm,
kind of what I'm doing to work on it,
but it's really difficult for me to talk,
to articulate the progress
and what's actually changed.
And she was like, well, do
you want me to tell you?
Right?
And so I actually wrote
down some of the stuff
that she said, 'cause I
asked her to repeat it.
Okay.
First of all, she kinda laughed again.
And it was like, what'd
you want me to tell you
what I've seen?
She's like, you're much more
in touch with your emotions,
which has translated into
the way that we communicate,
me and her communicate.
Been married for 20 years.
Spent many of those years,
if we were arguing about something,
my main goal was to get a
point across, to debate,
to be like, this is why I think
that I'm right about this,
and these are my supporting,
this is the supporting evidence
versus worrying about connecting.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Or just saying, this is how I feel.
Like I've literally changed
the way that we argue
about things by saying,
well, this is what I'm feeling right now.
And it isn't, I feel that
you're a jerk about it.
It's just like, no, this
is the emotional response
that I'm having right now.
And she's already there
because she's been doing,
and that's completely changed the way,
that's changed conflict resolution.
I didn't even know that
until she pointed it out.
She's like, you don't get mad as much.
I mean, again, that's something
that I didn't really have.
You really don't have a way
to perceive yourself in that way.
She said we are closer
than we've ever been.
And I was like, well, you know what?
I recently told somebody
that I thought that too.
Oh, that has something to do with-
Emotions.
Therapy.
Yes, okay.
And then she says, and
think about the way that we,
the differences in the way
that we deal with our kids
since before therapy.
One of the things that our
therapist has really harped on
is this maintaining the relationship
with our kids as they age.
And as they get older
and get more independent,
Locke will be in his
senior year in high school,
resisting the urge to
datafy every situation
and to moralize, and to
correct, and to teach,
and to use every conversation
as an opportunity
to give my wise perspective,
versus using every
conversation as an opportunity
to connect emotionally.
And again, that's just not something that,
I love my kids.
I love being with my kids.
I love doing things and
having fun with my kids.
But usually if they start
talking about something,
my default is to be like
robot analyze situation,
give solution.
Like, it's just my personality.
You bring me a problem,
I'll come up with a solution real fast.
Versus bring me a problem,
and let me get into,
let me get behind that problem with you.
Let's not solve it.
Let's just agree that it's a problem
and connect emotionally.
These are things that have happened,
but I needed my wife to point them out.
So I guess my question for you is,
I think before you make
any of this decision,
you gotta talk to Christy about it.
Oh, sure. We're already talking about.
Yeah, but like if she were to be like,
oh no, like I've seen this
change in you in these ways,
or be like, no, I think
you need a new therapist.
Like, she's gonna know way better than me.
We had a fight last night, so.
But we're having a date tonight.
Okay.
Just gotta get the fight out of the way.
But the fight was, the
conflict was resolved,
but I did not, I kind of showed my ass.
So I didn't really
demonstrate a lot of progress
in any area.
So I don't know if tonight
is a good night to ask.
'Cause she might be like,
there's work to be done.
I mean, that is the sense I get.
It's like the, and in an
effort to wrap this up,
I think just the benefit
of kinda looking back.
The other thing was that
I looked back at my notes,
and they ended a year ago.
I stopped jotting down.
I think I wanna start that back up
because I'm sure Christy
can give me perspective
on all of this, and I'll
put that question to her
in terms of like how I've
changed or grown, if at all.
I know, I believe I have.
I've definitely survived a
lot of things I couldn't,
and that is saying a lot,
and it's not something to diminish.
You've had acute situations
that took a lot of energy and time.
But I do think I wanna
keep writing things down,
and I am gonna seriously
consider getting a new therapist.
And I think that came from within me.
That's not something that you
were, that wasn't your idea.
Does your therapist
listen to this podcast?
Why would he?
I don't think my therapist,
my therapist doesn't listen to it
because every time he refers
to it, he calls it earbuds.
So.
Yeah, yeah.
Just keep it that way.
I don't think he would.
And I do not correct him
because it's my way to know
if he's actually listening.
Boy, this is, therapy's tough.
What have we learned?
Is this a ringing endorsement.
No, to me, and it's funny 'cause we,
I've had two conversations
in the past month
with two close friends,
one who just started therapy
and feels the need to change therapist,
and one who just started therapist
and wanted to check in with
me after a few sessions
and just ask the question.
Like, it's hard to evaluate.
And he was thinking about it
from a financial perspective,
which is a note we wanna make.
I mean, being able to pay
for your own mental health
is a privilege that we have.
It's the luxury, sadly.
Sadly, that's the case.
But we were talking to
edits before the show
with Kiko and Jenna,
and they were both kind of
reminding us about like,
there are mental health
resources and groups,
and there are actually,
there's free resources
depending on your background
and things that you deal with.
And the community you live in.
Yeah.
How big it it.
There are ways to get
at some of the stuff.
There's affinity groups like LGBTQ.
I mean, if that's.
Or there's support groups.
Yeah, and sometimes that can
happen in a group setting
and doesn't necessarily
have to be one-on-one.
But if you can afford it,
try to make it happen.
But he was asking that
question 'cause he was like,
I'm spending a fair
amount of money on this,
and just like what?
And I find myself, like he was,
he's a lot, he's not like you,
but it was funny 'cause he did something
that you would have done,
which is he printed out
like a summary of himself
with background information,
like a resume that you give to a therapist
and send it to the therapist
before the appointment.
Yeah.
To kind of get it out of the way
so they didn't have to spend
a bunch of time talking.
I love that idea.
And he was like, the therapist was like,
no one has ever done this.
I don't know how to feel
about it, but thank you.
Really?
So, but I told him the same thing.
I was like, listen, man,
like I had to ask Jesse.
'Cause I can't immediately articulate.
You forget what's actually happening.
Therapy rolls around and I'm just like,
ah, man, I just wanna watch TV.
I don't find myself longing for
my next therapy appointment.
If I have to miss it, and I
end up going a full month,
I don't feel the need-
You get secretly happy.
No, I don't get secretly happy,
but I don't have this felt need of like
all this stuff building
up that's about to explode
the moment that the Zoom call starts.
But then what I find is that
when the Zoom call does start,
and I just start letting it flow-
It's there. That's your MO.
It's there. Right.
Yeah.
So-
So you're recommending therapy.
I'm recommending therapy,
but it's not, yeah, it's not
gonna be like some easy thing.
My actual recommendation,
to wrap things up,
is a book that I've been reading called
"Why We Sleep" by, I think
his name is Michael Walker.
Let me just make sure that's his name.
Matthew Walker.
This was like a New York Times
bestseller a few years ago.
And it's basically just all about sleep
and the importance of sleep.
Now I will say that, as I've
dug into it a little bit,
that there are some people,
some researchers out there who question
some of the conclusions he comes to.
Okay.
But so much of the book
is him just saying,
this was a study, a peer
reviewed study that was done
with these people, and this is what it.
He explores all these
different aspects of sleep,
and you will learn a lot
of really good information.
But I've just been absolutely blown away
at how, just reminded at how important
getting a good night's sleep is.
Like, if you don't wanna read the book,
then just get a good night's sleep.
Get seven to nine hours of
sleep every single night.
That would be my recommendation.
I like that.
But if you're interested in
that kind of information-
If I can sleep with my therapist,
maybe all my problems will be-
Right.
And I don't mean like that.
Yep, oh, I understand.
But it's just, it's a good book in general
with a lot of absolutely
fascinating information
that you would like here on
like a podcast or like NPR,
all put together into a
really fascinating book.
All right.
Well #EarBiscuits.
Let us know what do you think about this.
You don't have to give me advice.
I got enough people in my
life to help me with that.
But any other way that
you're dealing with this,
or if you wanna give Rhett
advice, use #EarBiscuits.
I'm sure you will.
Talk at you next week.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.